What causes low stomach acid? This week's live Q&A mentioned
ademia, and I have been told repeatedly that I have low-ired ademia.
I think that body has trouble absorbing minerals in general.
Okay, so the different types of ademia, many of them can be tied to HCl deficiency.
So your parietal cells and your stomach make hydrochloric acid.
And they do so in the presence of food that is in your stomach.
It also actually does so with the presence of you, even just starting to chew,
or actually, even your thinking about eating causes stomach secretion,
stomach cells to create and to create HCl.
The problem is, is things that we eat chemicals,
additives, flavorings, colorings, poisons, toxins, things like that,
can affect that cell production of HCl.
And when we have a decreased production of HCl that causes
probably the most common primary cause of health conditions
in our country. Because if I don't make it up HCl,
I'm not going to digest my food well.
I'm not going to be able to stimulate intrinsic factor,
because it's dependent on HCl production.
So I'm not going to be absorbing B12.
So that can lead to a B12 type ademia.
If I'm not digesting my food properly, it's going into my small
intestine only partially digested. It's putting a much greater
straight on my pancreas, and on my liver production of bile
for lipase. And it can irritate because
food is going into my small intestine only partially digested.
It can irritate my gut lining, can cause ultimately
gut issues and leaky gut syndrome, and cause all sorts of
health conditions. So that can lead to just a plethora
of health conditions. One could say you have whatever you're
trying to treat a patient regardless and what they have,
whether it be cancer or an autoimmune disease, you have to
start with a gut. So to start with a gut, you have to start
with the highest weight up even in the mouth.
And definitely your basic, you know, health
improvement has to start with HCl production.
Now, what do you do to help increase HCl production?
Well, you support your stomach by adding HCl
or an acid like apple cider vinegar to your diet with your meal.
So it takes stress off those parietal cells of the stomach,
those are the cells that bake HCl in your stomach. So by taking HCl
with your meals, you are taking some stress off your parietal
cells, allowing them to recover, allowing them to be
able to start creating HCl in a better fashion.
So taking HCl, I always suggest taking HCl with digestive enzymes
because if you have HCl production issues, you've already
overstressed your pancreas for a period of time.
So taking pancreatic enzymes with HCl is really the
way to go. So how do you know if your
anemia is because of low hydrochloric acid production?
Well, there are signs of hypochloridria. So
hypochloridria is low hydrochloric acid production.
I've created a video on our blog. So if you go to our website and just type in
hydrochloric acid, you'll see several blog posts on that and I've created
several videos on actually how that actually happens
physiologically and then what to do for correction and to help support and
protect your stomach and help that heal.
So can you know for sure that anemia is caused
HCl deficiency? No, but there are blood tests even in a standard CBC and
complete metabolic pedal that gives you hits
on hypochloridria. Now that stated in that video that you'll see
that blog posts are not going to get into that right now, but you can
you can look it for patterns in your CBC and complete metabolic pedal that
will suggest hypochloridria. That still doesn't say,
I mean, a person could have hypochloridria anemia and the anemia is not
caused from hypochloridria. So there's different types of anemia and you
want to get a differential diagnosis on that. So if you could have an anemia
due to poor absorption of iron, you could have anemia due to
issues with transfer and which is the enzyme that transfers
iron in your blood. You could have anemia due to B12 deficiency because you're
not consuming enough B12. You could have anemia due to
B12 deficiency because you're not absorbing B12 like I mentioned before.
That's you need what's this chemical that is made in your
stomach called intrinsic factor that's only created when
you have HCL production. So intrinsic factor is needed to absorb B12.
You could have an absorption issue in your gut simply because you have
a hyper-inflamed gut. So investigating what the cause of the inflammation
in the gut is from which is most commonly food sensitivity. So you have antibodies
to different foods and you're eating those foods and every time you eat those foods,
you're causing this inflammatory hyperfire in the gut and that's going to
decrease absorption of all your nutrients and certainly iron could be
in that category and your B vitamins could be in that category as well.
So you're trying to investigate what is going on. There's also anemia's
chronic disease. So if a person knows that they have cancer or kidney disease
or some other chronic disease, that can lead to anemia.
Then there's anemia due to iron loss. You definitely want to investigate that.
Let's say, well I don't have cancer. I don't have kidney disease. I'm actually
pretty healthy but I just have this long-standing anemia.
You want to look at anemia due to iron loss. So maybe
if you're a female, maybe you haven't really heavy periods. You want to investigate
that. Look at your hormones to help balance that.
Also, you could have anemia due to iron loss because you have a
slow bleed ulcer. So if you have a duodenal ulcer or a stomach ulcer or a
slow bleed, you could be losing iron that way. So you want to investigate that.
And the number one cause of that is H-pilora infections. And the number one
cause of H-pilora infections is hypochydria. So it kind of all cycles back to
hypochydria in some way, shape or form. Regardless of whether you have
people, you know, we always think there's just this one
day that if I just fix that, that everything's going to go away.
For most commonly, we have multiple comorbidities going on and you want to try to
to plug the holes in the dam along the way. So I would definitely look at hypochydria,
look at signs in your blood test that can hit towards that.
See all those on my video on the blog post.
And dealing with digging down to the ultimate cause of the endemia. You don't want
to ignore that because if you have a bleed somewhere
that isn't investigated, well, that could be deadly ultimately.
A long term that could be from cysts, you know, even ovarian cysts and things
like that, fibroids are really a common cause of endemia in women.
If you want to investigate that, it's very difficult to take care of a fibroid
naturally. You almost always have to do surgery to remove
the fibroid in order to get rid of the endemia. Long-term endemia issues
are just going to give you a lot of fatigue, could cause other ill health
issues. So you definitely want to try to dig to get to the bottom of that.